[Music]
thank you for joining me i'm lawrence
jones and tonight blue states
problems are coming to texas now you may
have heard that my home state of texas
just picked up
two congressional seats one from
california and one from texas
it's not hard to understand why texas is
a great place to raise a family
it's cleaner choice of school is more
prevalent and the cost of living is much
more affordable
americans want to be free they don't
like being restricted by government that
locked them down
massed them up and taxed them into
oblivion but people fleeing to texas
from cities like los angeles
or new york might be surprised to find
familiar problems waiting for them in
the lone star
state i mean austin the capital city of
austin is facing a crime
problem a drug problem and a homeless
problem basically
all the quality of life issues blue
state transplants
thought they were leaving behind
residents say they've never seen
anything
like this but the city leadership run by
democrats
well except for the long republican deer
they're completely denying it
so i went to austin myself to see it
watch
if you're down here you're ready to
party it's busy city we came out just
have some fun
it's a great time everybody's safe it's
america it's my home
[Music]
this used to be one of the crown jewels
of austin
but as you can see another tent city
it's never been like this before
i'm a democrat but i have learned my
lesson i'm freaked out
something needs to be done two years ago
the city council voted to get rid of a
city
ordinance that been camping on public
land and parks
the result 11 percent increase in the
homeless population
you have people that are assaulted
people who are robbed
we've had home invasions one night i was
at my neighbor's house and
we saw them cleaning their guns
you found needles yes i saw this thing
on the floor i didn't know what it was
i picked it up austin is starting to
look like
it's getting rough that is the last
thing i want to have happen
a guy's walking around with a machete
threatening people
it started with box cutters as a weapon
now we
sadly we joke that we're the machete
capital of texas
this may the city residents got their
voice back
when they voted in a landslide victory
to reinstate
prop b so what is the city leadership
doing here in austin
the city of austin lets them do whatever
they want
please do your drugs leave your needles
with uncapsulated little kids can find
them and get help
and aids it's ridiculous you were
harboring
drugs sex trafficking all sorts of crime
in these tents
and we as a people and as citizens are
left to fend for ourselves
do you want that to be the image of
austin one of the reasons i don't like
that image is because i don't think it's
true
a guy is walking around right outside of
city hall with a machete
threatening people that's illegal that's
breaking the law and
and and we're dealing with a with a
tough challenge
they voted to defund the police last
year and reallocate money
and as such officers are leaving at very
high rates
i think the cause of our illness that is
taking over our city
is failed leadership i gotta tell you i
talk with the cops
they tell me that they want to be able
to enforce the laws but they've been
told
stand back my police chief tells me
that's not true
i'm gonna fight and if i know one thing
is change is constant
and we're gonna vote them out we could
either escape or we could run from this
problem
or we can face it straight on and we can
make a positive change
you have a commitment to go and engage
these members of the public to come up
with some sort of solution
absolutely it's my practice and i've
been doing that
don't worry guys the great mayor is
dealing with it
do you see it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else